tick tock is officially the biggest uh
most visited website in uh uh on the
internet passing up google
cbs news for the first time tick tock
has surpassed facebook and google as the
most popular destination on the internet
storage software company cloudflare
found that ticktock was the most visited
website and most widely used social
media platform
cloudflare is ranking is based on how
much web traffic a site generated in
tick-tock first place then it's google
facebook microsoft apple amazon netflix
youtube twitter whatsapp and in regards
to social media platforms after tick
tock it's facebook youtube twitter
instagram snapchat snapchat's still
number six by the way interesting reddit
pinterest ahead of linkedin good for
snapchat it's an under
rated uh app by the way then it's cora
so what do you think about tick tock
becoming the the biggest website in the
world well look it's no secret it's
owned by bite dance which is owned by
the ccp or whatever you know china and
um you know i guess look on the bright
side other than than tick tock the top
nine are american companies
congratulations america we're killing it
but
i don't know tick tock has blown up it's
exploded over the last couple you just
had a video that took off for you on
dude i've never i had a video that got a
quarter million views in one day it was
insane yeah talking shout out to my
people in portugal talking about uh
jeffy
they're they they don't call them cafe
and portugal they don't speak they speak
portuguese okay i got it
um
but it blew up but
you know you mentioned something
yesterday that i want to get your
opinion on i think there's a 99 chance
trump gets reelected
i'm sorry that he runs again i apologize
i apologize there's a freudian slip
right there
i'll vote for trump i don't care no um
where's the 99 championship hero elected
50 50. oh you're 50 50 okay i mean
that's just easy i just had coin flip
got it but um
i would say 51 uh at this point
like okay so you're saying trump's
probably gonna get reelected yeah i mean
look it is what it is at this point i
don't think biden is doing anything to
improve his poll numbers and you know
lower than carter first time ever where
his his poll is officially lower than
caught not as low as trump let's not
forget about that no no it's the lowest
ever in in since carter he dropped his
rating is net approval rating fell below
carter my point is this what's your
point
um
if trump gets reelected yep what are the
chances tick tock still stays number one
or even stays atop he's gonna go
straight after the same enemy because he
doesn't think the enemy changed he'll go
straight after china
and remember remember here's one thing
that people don't realize you know this
whole statistic that came up about
visualizing the 94 trillion world
economy in one chart and it says world
economy tops 100 trillion dollars in
2022 next year yeah 2022 the world
economy is going to be what 100 trillion
dollars right over 100 and 100 first
time ever we're going to be 100 trillion
dollar the world economic output will
exceed 100 trillion dollars for the
first time and it'll take china a little
longer than previously thought to
overtake the united states as the number
one economy report showed on sunday
british consolency that
uh uh predicted china will become the
world's top economy and dollar terms by
2030 two years later after forecast on
last
euros world economic economic league
table report india look to overtake
france next year and in britain in 2023
and the race for the world's top economy
and they're saying india by 2031 will be
number three economy
adam india will be number three economy
in the world now what does that mean by
2031 here's what it means yeah what's
the one country that banned a hundred
apps from china india india did right
india has the audacity they banned tick
tock though
tick tock's not available in india right
they have the audacity to ban can you
imagine how xi jinping feels here's a
guy that just published a book that told
amazon you cannot put any of my negative
ratings amazon doesn't put any of the
negative reviews of xi jinping on amazon
insane think think about that right
can you pull up that story xi jinping uh
uh comes out with a book on amazon and
they the amazon does not let any of the
one-star reviews be up there amazon book
rating yeah let's see if the article
comes up or not
right there okay amazon reportedly took
down reviews of chinese president's book
after demands okay go a little lower
amazon
retails on amazon reportedly scrubbed
reviews of chinese book xi jinping book
from one of its sites and helped promote
uh other forms of propaganda reuters
reported amazon received an edict
from beijing a personal a person
familiar with the edict said a
negative review of xi jinbing's book
promoted a bookseller to stop allowing
any customer ratings and reviews in the
country another person familiar with the
story said i think the issue with
anything under five stars the company
also partners with the st by the way
this is a reuters
story yeah volume three of ji's book
were reportedly listed as a bestseller
on china books and amazon site creator
and partnership with an arm of nation's
propaganda apparatus okay so we know
what game he's playing he's playing all
the propaganda game behind closed doors
he can tell amazon to give him all the
five-star reviews they have to listen to
him india is not afraid of them india's
gonna be number three in the world india
long term could potentially even pass up
america okay because they got simply
just more bandwidth more people and we
know the average age in india versus
china and u.s the average age in india
is what 26 27 28 the average age here is
38.4 the average age in china is 38.8
so if trump does get re-elected if trump
does get re-elected
i think the first thing he targets is he
goes back and he finishes what he
started with china and i think china if
you think kovit was ugly i think if
trump gets elected i'm telling you right
now there's a very high likelihood he
does get re-elected but if he does get
reelected the next big thing you ought
to worry about isn't covet the next big
thing you got to worry about is a cyber
warfare
global power outage type of a situation
where china's an expert in right now
that they can pull off
that's what they're going to do under
trump 1.0 was kovit under trump 2.0 will
be a major new pandemic that has nothing
to do with virus it's got to do with our
lifestyle changes so what do you see the
the positives and negatives and the
ramifications specifically with china if
trump gets realized here's the name you
know they're not a fan of him yeah i
don't think that's a secret here's a
positive here's a negative i'll give you
both okay
to me
the negative is
america is going to look like it's in
shambles okay when trump gets back into
the office let's just see if he's saying
optics wise oh it's going to be in
shambles because china is going to make
america look like
it's divided at the highest level yeah
even worse than now i think it's going
to be way worse i don't think it's going
to be better i think you're going to see
america in shambles the only way it
won't be is in the following way the
only way it won't be is in the following
way
if america gets so bad the next 12 24
months that both dems and republicans
come together and they say let's get
this crazy trump guy back because we
think he can do it what's your
likelihood of that happening is what
not very slim very slim right of
democrats saying let's agree trump
democrats not all democrats all you need
is five ten percent i'm not talking all
democrats i'm talking i'm talking about
influencer democrats like a bill maher
comes out and says you know what i'm not
going to lie to you i'm starting to kind
of sit there and say
if we're going to play against a country
like china we need somebody crazy like
trump he just needs to make a comment
like that and other people will follow
just like nobody thought lebron james
the other day was going to post on
instagram with spiderman pointing
fingers at everybody saying is it flu is
it cold is it coveted what the hell is
it did you ever think
lebron was going to tweet this out and
clay travis comes out and says
finally lebron and i agree on something
what is lebron trying to say here he's
sick of the fact that they can't even
play the game because one day it's a
call one day it's a flu one day to covet
so if somebody from that side comes out
and says
i think we need somebody like trump then
america is united then they can't divide
us
but if america is still divided and
trump gets elected it's going to be
worse than what it was before but the
reality of it is if you don't get
somebody like that that's not afraid of
going directly against china long term
america is going to be controlled by
china so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you